Zendaya is an insanely versatile actress
Euphoria Dune the greatest showman
Spider-Man but what goes down behind the
scenes and how she morphs into these
characters is pretty wild yeah it looks
fun but it's clearly hard work because
the rules are not just emotionally
challenging but also super physically
demanding what comes to mind is that
absolutely brilliant set on Euphoria you
know the spinning room where the actors
had to well do their job act and at the
same time walk on the floor as it moved
under their feet basically they built
this room that rotated completely around
so when Roo walks down that hallway he
walks out that bathroom breaks away
which allowed our technocrine to
basically Dolly into the hallway if you
think about Rue's character though and
the story it almost feels like this set
is the most natural solution for the
scene I mean ain't that the point sure
the design fulfills its technological
purpose but it also kind of reflects the
mental state of the characters the
roommate Zendaya feel dizzy and sorry
oriented and that's exactly what her
character was experiencing in the show
but let's backtrack and answer the most
fundamental question in Zendaya's career
but how did Zendaya get into acting she
tried many things as a kid she played
basketball soccer did track and dancing
but her real passion started showing
itself when her mom started working at a
theater to supplement her income as a
teacher Zendaya asked her mom once to
bring her to a technical rehearsal she
was maybe seven or eight and soon enough
Zendaya started doing conservatories
with California Shakespeare Theater
herself then her agent in San Francisco
said hey they're looking for people in
LA and when we asked her if she wanted
to she was like yeah and six months
later she booked her first Disney job
so Zendaya did a few little commercials
before moving to LA and she's done some
pretty lucrative AdSense hello designers
some of these are like art pieces
literally you can put these ads on your
wall and just stare at the captivating
visuals and Zendaya looking Fierce this
Bulgari unexpected wonders campaign was
shot in Rome Italy and it's filled with
beauty and Grand architecture you can
feel the Magic in the halls of the
castle looking at Zendaya's grace and
elegance it's amazing to see how she
transformed since her Disney days she's
a global ambassador of multi-billion
dollar companies now and she gets to
wear jewelry pieces that cost millions
of dollars
[Music]
hey hey
now that's just beautiful and the film
she does also happen to cost millions of
dollars the budget for Spider-Man no way
home was 200 million and dune 165 mil
and well you get the idea she had a
smaller part in the first dune film but
the second movie has her hard at work in
the desert all just so we got a little
more Zendaya screen time as opposed to
the seven minutes we got in the first
film so for Spider-Man she gets to play
a super cool character and work with two
of her best friends Jacob adalon and of
course love of her life Tom Holland
while Z was a star before she joined the
MCU it was definitely a level up and put
her on the map in a different way I mean
she earned it considering all the stunts
she had to do literally flying through
the streets of New York just to get a
shot which funnily enough they didn't
even end up using in the Final Cut
anyway but that doesn't matter we did it
and it was amazing and I'm proud of
myself for doing it you dropped 100 feet
we did it I mean at least she was used
to being on wires and flying high after
she made Zac Efron fall in love with her
in the greatest Showman we're not joking
he literally said that Zendaya was his
favorite on-screen kiss ever now that's
High Praise thank you thank you so much
Wow Girls spent plenty of time on a
trapeze flying and in the recording
booth capturing those sweet sweet vocals
which is a place she was pretty
comfortable working already because
let's remember that she's had a full-on
singing career before I get to that
though gotta give a shout out to
Euphoria maybe one of the most powerful
and visceral shows of Our Generation and
wildly intense for her to perform as
well that was a day I didn't need to act
at all like tears were coming all right
now yes she's a talented performer but I
think we're just beginning to see how
wildly talented she is in all aspects of
life she's already got some plans
brewing for what she wants to pursue
next hopefully directing you know
here would want to be directed in a film
by Zendaya okay the better question is
probably who wouldn't want to be I mean
one day I hope I
hope ton of time behind the camera when
she wasn't performing shadowing the no
way home director John Watts just so she
could get more of a feel for how the
whole machine works when she wasn't
acting she was just chilling watching
the monitors and seeing all the pieces
came together and well with a mentor
like John and experiences working with
some of the most talented artists in the
world I think my process is just like
find the camera that you really want I
get it and then you just start shooting
I'm curious what kind of movie she'll
choose as her first will it be an action
an intense psychological Thriller she
said she was meant to direct an episode
of euphoria in season two but she was
too busy acting her heart out so fingers
crossed she actually does get to direct
an episode in the third season she's
definitely proved herself just ask those
two Emmys my greatest wish for for
Euphoria was that it could help heal
people mission accomplished here I think
while waiting to sit in that director's
chair Zendaya also regularly sits in the
driver's seat of the producer's chair no
for real if you check out her IMDb
credits real quick you'll see that she
actually produced a bunch of stuff
everything from music videos to full-on
features and of course as an exec
producer for Euphoria everyone seems to
be so obsessed with the show so we think
that's a pretty strong hint at how well
she's gonna do with the rest of her
project and let's not forget all those
Emmys remember that moment when she went
viral back in 2020 that Emmy made her
the youngest person ever to win one the
world is obsessed and it makes sense why
I was like yo we should just take in
this moment and now what to look forward
or two because there's so much Zendaya
content on its way and we are here for
it she's diving into this film about
professional tennis called The
Challengers it's directed by Luca
guadagnino because of course she is
Zendaya as a tennis pro turned coach
sounds great then for something totally
different she's doing the Ronnie Spector
biopic called be my baby so get excited
because here we'll get to see a
beautiful combo of her talents more
Zendaya singing yes please she's going
to be starring in and producing a movie
called a white lie with Reese
Witherspoon's production company okay so
let's take a sec to do a real quick roll
call genevil NIV Tom Holland Sam
Levinson John Watts Reese Witherspoon
Luca guadagnino yes these are all
legends that Zendaya has worked with and
now we can add another very impressive
name the Francis Ford Coppola yep and
let's remember the fact that she's still
only in her 20s we've been watching her
grow up and become this Mega star a lot
of people would have a hard time
handling all that attention and work
with such Grace but that's what makes
Zendaya such an inspiration to her fans
she cares she loves her work and just
wants to live every day to the fullest
she loves her life so much that one day
when she was asked who she'd trade
places with for a day if she could she
literally said no one because her life
is the best and I can't disagree with
that what is it for you that makes
Zendaya such a star how down to earth
she is her performances her seemingly
never-ending Talent let me know what you
think in the comments